ah yes the bee sting King in the Rat
King
[Music]
I used to listen to Backstreet Boys
sometimes I didn't play it but if
somebody else played it then I would
hear it you weren't tell him to turn it
off I don't either
I would be like oh these guys are
[ __ ] and then I would like kind of
enjoy me time I that shit's weak I enjoy
a nice backstreet do you yeah bro we
grew up on a back street so I guess I'm
familiar like but that would that's not
what they were talking about it was like
they were talking about like kind of
sexy [ __ ]
yeah something can relate to it though
young man and a lot of my glitter on
them glitter yeah a lot more freshly
shaved especially the men's think boys
you remember in sync Oh in sick now that
was different because that JT Justin
Timberlake for those of you that don't
know it the lead of that band you could
just see the talent booze from his pores
like he was gonna ditch those losers and
move on and do big things
yeah the one guy just had sideburns that
was his only skill and then the other
the other one looked like a muppet baby
yeah I mean JT was like basically
probably one of the top six or seven
wiggers of all time I think whoa lazy no
wicker no JT come on bro bro he's and I
wish you would see his 23andme results I
bet you think there's some oh he's
definitely because he can dance I mean
he can do different he's very sim acid
you know he's multi look at him he's
like he's like a Sammy Sosa colored
Jamie Foxx
he's like Sammy Sosa's blue-eyed son
yeah kind of how he looks rest that
bents
Happy New Year yeah you too man yeah
nighty baby 2019 coming wrong with the
king in the same thing in touch me don't
touch me dude it's cool it's cool you
wore your [ __ ] uh overall what the
[ __ ] what is this
I'm glad you wear your long johns into
this these are longer these are 100%
cotton yeah that's what long johns are
bro yeah well thank you for dressing up
today this didn't you know artificial
stuff is a hundred percent cotton dude
whatever bro you look like a backup
dancer for be honest actually I like it
like you're going through rehearsal
do we do every her cyl today he look
like a do it like rehearsal for
Nickelback you know they don't have
dancers oh you uh yeah you you look
basically you're like a fat guy dude
that's shaped well you're not even
really strong but the thing work dude
yeah they're like it worked
you look like Jared Leto sidepiece but
he dressed you this more like those put
the [ __ ] pajamas back so I can suck
your dick when I wash what is wrong and
these are eggshell white and these are a
hundred percent cotton yeah bro those
aren't long johns where I come you're
not who they're not yeah they are
they're very relaxing you know whatever
um yeah dude you're not even you're
basica I thought about this yesterday
dude you're kind of like a fat guy you
know just get out wait I'm not strong
wait that's all you working out though
[ __ ] you get the body of Kermit the Frog
vegans well that dude have lured your a
flat ass well really yeah bro get that
you're the only dude in Louisiana with a
flat ass then why if I you know soiled
myself in kindergarten or whatever the
backup pants they would give me or from
this other boy named Burt that had Down
syndrome oh and they got dumpers oh dude
they got the gay in the tray baby they
got junk in trays on all of them la face
90s booty yeah you know saying la face
with the DES booty gentle booty but yeah
dude I've realized you kind of look like
you're well molded kind of fat but very
contoured fat it's like you're not yeah
some some some say it's a figure it's
I'm saying it's a figure yeah just saw
and yours yours is like you you're built
like Kermit the Frog I saw you working I
was like oh wow that is not inspiring oh
dude that must be years of the drugs you
did and it just gave you how you give me
give me a dick to the coke and have that
party like usually people shred it for a
while like help well look I tell you
this when I first did cocaine the first
time I ever bought it I thought it was a
um performance-enhancing drug that's
what somebody to which it is yeah and I
did a couple grams I ran about eight
miles
when I was in Louisiana State in about
seven minutes I'll Ram pretty quick in
then I jumped over a fence into
somebody's backyard dude and uh it got a
little bit dicey but it was um you know
it was nighttime I'm good bro we brought
in we brought in the new years the right
way mat The Comedy Store at the Comedy
Store y'all good show man it was a fun
show
I was really fun it was fun we made it
happen and we're still alive and we got
an opportunity to make King it or sting
it that's right dude and shout out to
all the people who made King and the
sting the number one podcast in the
world yeah I think it was at the Middle
East
oh really least watched this mainly
young as they call them Muslims we call
them Slim's the slim oh all right and
who else did it then Bix arabic's
the Chinese the knees knees the knees
thanks for meeting us number one these
yeah the knees boy how about the Rings
Korean people from Iran Iran Iranian
Marines yeah Koreans the maria's oh yeah
are them lepers people that are actually
just lepers another leprosy this is but
no thank you very much one it days are
just pilots you know I'm saying like
we're still trying to figure the format
out this is yeah I lose [ __ ] for yes
today - yeah I'm still doing debate club
can your sting it yeah we got a couple
of other we have some ship for you yeah
we're gonna come up with a new Twitter
launched a new topic at the end today
and let's get into it I'm in in the next
week we kicked the official show off
because we're in our new studio baby
don't be nervous don't be scared girl I
feel overwhelmed kind of do you yeah
makes me feel a little bit better but I
still feel overwhelmed yeah watch your
mouth when you talk about JT though oh
dude should we kick this off just kick
it debate club first oh debate club
first time a bro from our mascot no he's
back human golfer here report for duty
[ __ ] came the sting by the way
of feel the best of the best rat king
bond and the former UFC enemy
assassin the sting Brendan Schaub get
your question you're being hired to be a
mascot for your show just tell me what I
need to do I'm from Saratoga Springs New
York 40 minutes north of Albany I have a
true box from age 14 I still make a
cameo the gym once in a while 33 now and
most people find someone entertaining
but who's to say so I'm gonna mention
alcohol which one do you prefer and
which one's worse for you is that Joey I
mean real quick for the listeners in
general we don't need a full bio like
that yeah he gets a pass he gets a pass
he's 20 minutes north of Albany and I'm
to take a left off Morrison Street I'm
there I live with my mom I'm in the base
rail you see the [ __ ] hole when I got
upset she wouldn't give me my dinner I
went BAM [ __ ] there is you good enough
if you're not watching on the youtubes
there's a hole in the wall right behind
this guy and this is one of those
familial holes this is a family induced
hole correct and this hole came there
was a lot of stuff that happened before
this was a domestic violence yeah yes
they call it Davey Boy the mom wasn't
doing something that he wanted he got
variable yeah this is only warm Janet
you know but uh
all right pot versus alcohol you uh you
pick first men debating Club well I
can't drink alcohol right now so I'm
gonna go with and I can't use pot either
but I will I'll go with pot I'm gonna go
with pot you're taking pot yep all right
let me tell ya alcohol okay go ahead bro
I'll say this about pot man pot is
something that you can easily you can
use it a lot of different ways
smoke it hide it in your body you could
put it in your butt you could drip it
cannabinoid oil you can put it in a
smoothie pot you can take a hit off of a
pot blow it into a buddy's face or into
a girl's mouth if you're trying to get
her high and you know household I don't
think you can blow it in her [ __ ]
dude that is very French I think but
this is something you could get that hit
and do something wild with it you could
put it into a cake you know now
you can do that with alcohol but it's
only a couple of cakes rum cake and um
you know Ginger Snaps you know so
outside of that pot is that you know
that that that beautiful thing you can
blow it into the air vents and get your
folks all [ __ ] up and do beautiful
stuff with it and God made it nah man
out this one's easy alcohol this one's
super easy alcohol name anytime to say
why it's easy yeah say it's the same
name the time when you went to a [ __ ]
party everyone's just smoking weed and
dudes were getting their dicks I tell no
you haven't shots titties are out the
alcohols flowing liquid courage you're
heard of liquid smoke courage not me but
I can never bro that would be snow
aggeridge smoke that doesn't know you
can do pole bro smoke courage does not
exist
well liquid courage does so ugly dudes
like you can hook up with hot chicks
that's why Hall works bro yeah you don't
have that haircut and get your dick
sucked without girls being drunk so high
they just laugh this isn't a haircut
this is an upper ambiance whatever bro
but if when you're high you're here
looks even more ridiculous when you're
drunk you look sexy you should be going
alcohol bro all right I'm gonna be frat
parties all right come to my party do
you have any drinks nope just weed all
right no one's getting their dicks ugh
well not a party and they get all
whiskey okay it's getting wild
I respect your I respect your side I'm
gonna say this my closing arguments will
be this but weed is that thing you could
blow it into the wind and let it go
downhill and pick up a couple of babies
and have them climb up the hill to come
see you you know I'm saying all right
you you know you spray a beer into the
air and that [ __ ] just kind of falls
off to its side you know like last night
champagne was a popping champagne was an
option [ __ ] reefer you know I'm saying
right but a John would have brought a
couple family Oh sort of fire yeah Irish
and California you chief up that John
it's gonna bring a couple of people in
you know again everyone's laughing
then I laugh at the way you dress you're
here alcohol it makes you look cooler
dude if you want to be drunk yeah if you
want to be drunk man be drunk yeah you
know and I'll be high bro and when
you're high you meet people you meet
black guys and cool stuff you go to
videos when you're drunk who do you meet
huh Satan
yeah people on
bridges and rolls yeah trolls ood and
hot chicks good in the bad bro trolls
watch what weed will make any chick feel
hot dude I remember bro I remember being
high I mean so high dude I felt like I
had [ __ ] six eyes bro and four of
them were in my [ __ ] heart and I
remember making love to women and their
bodies do it even if their body had a
little bit of a was kind of a junkyard
it felt beautiful and that's marijuana
you know you never hooked up with a
slump er when you're hammered you never
hooked up with a grateful to just cuz
you were drunk
cuz you both look kind of like [ __ ] it
it's the end of the night we both been
sipping our martinis you look like [ __ ]
martinis dude where are you drinking at
macaroni grill you're livin large bro
I'll be at Chili's bro all right you
never had a full rack of ribs and if in
couple beers deep and an awesome blossom
and getting getting bald that [ __ ]
know many how many appetizers you throw
into it I'm not hooking up with a big
gal for no reason bro you are for your
drunk bro yeah if you're high you're not
cuz they look funny I'm not you're gonna
think you're [ __ ] with rhinoceros if I
make I [ __ ] your brain up dude are you
talking about getting all South African
bro yeah good look I'll get it you know
call me the animal kingdom bro yeah only
Steve heroin boy you're drunk grateful
twos dude grateful too it's called a
Grateful Dead and they don't like damn
you don't kill Jesus bro I'm gonna say
dude look man I don't think I would
rather do weed and now this debate isn't
over because it never ends here and Nick
and chin have some more information for
you fellas right now it's just getting
started
yeah yeah cuz every week we're gonna be
getting the fan responses on every
single one of these topics we're gonna
put out a Friday episode that's all fan
fan submitted you just have to get your
submissions and your responses in the
day this episode comes out by the end of
the day Wednesday
yeah may be a good time is what 11 p.m.
Pacific Standard boom what else we got
Pacific Standard you goddamn baby that's
what we driving
2300 hours Wow 11 Pacific Central Time
number 2 Roberto Morales oh yeah
what a feel would a big dog the first
game is rbirtle coming out of the Bay
Area California and want to see if you
guys wanted to debate a quick topic for
me you know I'm talking about real deal
no Taco Bell shape Mexican food and like
some real deal no Panda Express shape
Chinese food what do you got what do you
got it Mexican versus Chinese being
racist in this much so you know what I'm
going to say you guys take it easy leave
a lot of us for peace no I don't know
she's from Russia
viva la raza was he on top of the
[ __ ] bridge was he well first of all
that was in fighting fires
yeah or leaks I use highest [ __ ] or he
was cooking something yeah it's tough to
tell shout out to that dude yeah I'm
kicking Morales off Senor Morales I'm
kicking this one off this one's so
[ __ ] easy I'll see my girls from
Guadalajara so I eat a lot of authentic
Mexican a lot of kiss the Dallas and the
thing is is Mexican food authentic
Mexican
[ __ ] destroys authentic Chinese food
Nate's a month
Chinese food you've already dude Mexican
food if you ever had real Molay or
[ __ ] salsa or taquitos or [ __ ]
slob sauce you ever had any of that bro
your ad here at SOPA Orsola your apple
solid yeah you ain't ready bro I've had
some bad my life bro I've had some dirty
posole of my life brother trust me I
lost my virginity behind the but Tiffany
Lanes bowling alley over there for
highway 190 do a good still in operation
good [ __ ] fish talking like some
authentic Mexican [ __ ] fish there's a
Asian dish if we're now you're
incorporating my side of the net know
what I want to say is this dude first of
all yeah Mexican you basically shoot
anything put cheese on it brother you
know what I mean and II while meant they
you know Papa but what I'm saying is
this Chinese food comes from I've had
great Chinese food
says Juan compiled No General Tso's
[ __ ] drill towie damn drilled core
other and that [ __ ] spot about $90 a
slice
dude I'll give you beef and broccoli but
other than that you ain't [ __ ] beef and
broccoli bro dude that's from the
Netherlands I'll give you sweet sour
chicken outside that though next food
[ __ ] you up dude I've had real Chinese
food where you're eating it and a
Chinese you come and just kick you in
the [ __ ] neck oh man really
yeah dude I'm talking about beheading
each other I'm talking about you can
taste in the [ __ ] distance you can
taste your ancestors [ __ ] looking for
fertile soil boom there I heard when you
eat ramen noodles that the seasoning is
Chinese man's sweat is it really that's
why her powdered down
powder powdered sweat oh wow yeah I
could see that if you had enough of it
and you really cooked it down but
Chinese are so Mexican look bro name a
real Chinese food dumplings doc you guys
need a lot [ __ ] duck oh the Chinese
god is the worst greasiest [ __ ] ducks so
easy to kill okay you're play duck
hunter on Nintendo easiest game there
dude I've definitely I've look I've
caught a bunch of ducking I'll say this
duck probably one of the four or five
easiest birds to catch super easy turkey
duck one two and I've been in China when
I've seen somebody they grab a duck by
the what is this Hopalong part coming
out on stupid neck the neck yeah and
then they grab it and then they just
flip it over and beat it right against
the ground Chinese don't give a [ __ ] you
you don't want to be a duck you know
want to be a female
yeah China dude dude I was in Vietnam we
paid a guy $40 to kill a pig right in
front of us you know oh that's it dude
Mexican food bro first of all shoot your
pants oh very [ __ ] your pants
yeah hit three right kind of picante and
cilantro you get some of that bro you
will [ __ ] your pants
what are you saying all right that's how
they talk dude yeah I've been around it
Wow but it's the same thing they got
four ingredients for us I talked to a
bell you realize a gordita is just a
double decker with some you realize the
tostadas a Mexican pizza just fold it
twice and a lot of that lettuce that you
guys are making right
now is bad you guys have a lot of bad
lettuce well you're referring to
Chipotle yeah and I will say this
Chipotle makes the best goddamn taco on
planet did it really yeah bro get that
soft taco with the white [ __ ] rice
and white only let me put the chicken on
top hmm Oh God sounds can't beat that
bro you know I don't know you ever want
your very good anymore right you ever
had a good Chinese food truck no it's
got a good [ __ ] Mexican truck yeah
yeah oh dude if somebody had a gun full
of Mexican food this is how I made my
decision just now if somebody had a gun
full of Mexican food or a gun full of
Chinese food not let one of them shoot
it right into my [ __ ] mouth you don't
want that [ __ ] orange chicken flying
down oh now you want that you want that
punk case oh yeah bro yeah bro I want
some of it it [ __ ] land on my back
you know queso on your [ __ ] that but
nose of yours this is not it's a very
unique no it's good bro I'm saying the
button nose is a good thing no my
family's from Nicaragua in Rome you know
I know bro let's cover it with cheese
bit and I can't even breathe that good
yeah but um alright dude what else we
got so I can't walk then the last thing
I'll say about this Chinese food I'll
give you guys orange chicken okay and
I'll say this much Chinese food it is
the it's good right when you order it
that's it though it and it it loses its
value immense like the minnow it is the
Bruce Willis what's that movie he was in
this Rob dead Fred what does the movie
he was in die hard die hard
it's the die hard of of cuisine see that
[ __ ] starts ticking pop quiz hot shot
pop quiz hot shot 40 minutes later it is
it's like eating dry Waldo worse now
Mexican foods like Clint Eastwood about
you everything's good for a long time
forever yeah that shit's good it stands
up over time oh yeah don't heat up an
enchilada from last week delicious but
build a wall right outside of my ass
because stuffs coming out it's coming
over stuff is coming over all right what
else we got all right number three from
Keith McAvoy
and what do you got shout outs all the
keys out there's a lot of Keith's a lot
of keys
yeah a lot of keys out there and yes let
us know what you think about Chinese
food vs. Mexican what do you think about
points and we tweet why don't we go to a
damn source right here chin that Chinese
is Koreans that's like asking that's
like asking a guy from our GT know he
thinks of Mexican food no it's like
asking a guy from Louisiana what the
[ __ ] of you from Alabama like you know
what I'm saying you don't know chime in
but I got some ideas dude would you try
and Baby Gap look at you Jesus Christ
well yeah way to get braces white chin
have to know about Chinese come on Korea
bro huh and you call him a [ __ ] earlier
I didn't call him a [ __ ] I said that's
their team name no they got married in a
house you call him a [ __ ] I would never
say that about I heard it he's not even
from China the audio we're from Korea
you idiot I know bro but that that that
defense of wherever you're from how is
it he called me a [ __ ] I take offense
huh
some eyes but I'll call you something
you go ahead you're racist you know
here's Keith McAvoy I got something for
y'all to debate me and my roommate who's
not here at the moment but it's what I
be in there that we trying to see who's
hotter Margot Robbie or Rihanna
I don't know me y'all help us fellas
fellow this is a tough one one eye isn't
bigger than the other but we can't put
that in there that's gonna break that
[ __ ] guy's heart man dude that's life
bro like your song does Oh Brendan
Schaub whatever I here's our [ __ ] up
faces [ __ ] up looks like yes tongue
like a be easy coming That's Life bro I
came out my mama's womb like this that's
just me could that's like Tina [ __ ]
dolphin me like that thing's great think
with one of his eyes is bigger than the
other I wound up like this what's up
mean up a woman I was when I was bigger
than the other not a big deal you're
right he more posed the question and
made fun of him he was just like why is
one eye bigger okay that's fair okay
maybe he's like it's not I'm high as
[ __ ] or I'm a pirate in the off day and
I'm sure like you're my off time I
[ __ ] I'm a pirate for kids well I'll
say it is that man right there he seemed
like he's from another country and he
said he had a roommate who I didn't see
what sounds like a Dateline episode
sounds like he's lying in what did he
ask about Rihanna Margot Robbie Margot
Robbie I don't either
I don't like Rihanna so cuz she's just
overused oh [ __ ] oh voice Nick how dare
you do get your boner ready bro to get
that little boner spice the [ __ ] up like
play-doh phoner
cuz you're going to order more pants to
hold it well they're so [ __ ] tight
lean to your dick wrinkles from here
well quit looking down there Bulls a lot
of the resume should look like [ __ ]
about Rihanna me to look at Rihanna bro
I'm more here you look at that chocolate
skin and she likes him with a dick taste
she looks like Reggie Miller but way hot
wow that is [ __ ] ah bro you hurt my
feelings man
you hurt my feelings that's my girl I'm
gonna take offense to it dude I'd like
to see her and John Starks [ __ ] go at
it damn John Starks is not the guy from
I'm not Iron Man Game of Thrones
anything environment
who's the one I get to cheer for you
Margot Robbie's then you hate Rihanna so
you get mark Margot Robbie yeah cuz I
love you and who is your British guy
Margot Robbie nah man come on wolf of
Wall Street
I saw wolf walk she's Australian put
another shrimp on the barbie oh wow died
me died me bro dude you ain't her type
I'll take that right now bro I am
retention I mean that type I'll take
that right now can I see you another
photo over so I can see more of her
unless you meet her out of a a meeting
you ain't getting a sniff of that girl
a about them tats you know boy she's got
some real heat sex yeah bro couple one
two flowers dude I would break my neck
just to [ __ ] watch out soft my pinky
toes for Wow that's all her you cut off
your ear to [ __ ] her no really yeah
didn't she that's a Vincent van Chyna
you're talking about there she ain't
cutting off my ear to [ __ ] any couple
wants that jaw on a two bro um now tell
me about this young lady does she seem
like a nice person
oh yeah sure suck you dry bro well
anybody could suck you dry dude no she's
you know tell ya she's nice but a
security guard I'll saddle suck you dry
right now if you jump his car his car's
broken out no I'm not looking for that
does he look like her
but does she seem like a nice person do
you know I don't know her personally I'm
sure she's [ __ ] fine I don't know
and now if iff at the bet who's the more
loving person between her and Rihanna
Rihanna's gonna [ __ ] your proper and
then dip out the next morning
really and never call you but she [ __ ]
that boy he almost died on that roller
skate around no Sean Kingston did she
yeah she's also [ __ ] some Arab dude
who's like super rich who's like a
prince yeah anybody could use the toilet
girl I think well I don't know what that
is
dude you're so immature you know what a
toilet girl is uh-uh it's like your
cleaning lady
mmm no well kind of but for all you
don't know a toilet girl is you know
when you're on the Instagram you just
see some smoke show she's like kind of
yachting de buyer you know I got she
doing good by the next picture she's on
like a [ __ ] penthouse but no one else
is around those rich Arabs fly them out
right like by the boatload really damn
girls yeah make him do something strange
for some change like the handcuff in the
toilet and [ __ ] their mouths and stuff
oh my god yeah yeah but then they come
back out here and they got 200k in the
bank I'll be a toilet boy I'll be a
toilet man bro King and sting it toilet
men what willful film from Dubai I don't
even know where I am Ewok like I'm gonna
watch this now I don't want to I'm just
educating you on the way I'm shutting
this down dude I'm not talking about
this if this is the kind of stuff that
they're talking about debate club I'll
take Margo Robert you get
[ __ ] what's his name Rhiannon I don't
know who who mark Robert is but I'll
take Renato bro you fine go out there
with Rihanna who's been on a boat and
[ __ ] people in the bathroom or
whatever you mean live in bro yeah
living I guess sure living the best life
yeah sounds really wrong you're who is
the best 401k who's in bed by 9:00
I don't give a [ __ ] what else we got bro
you guys chime in so we'll give me a
better argument yeah what do you got in
shares a 401 k us yeah I think Margot
really Sheen's racism so don't not Maris
he's out do you date whites or whatever
date a black girl I've hooked up with a
black girl we're at was it off of a knot
with Van Nuys Boulevard
oh you channels thing on her ceiling I
was like reflected but it wasn't a
mirror now was that Takaya different
what's Takaya next inch place why would
it be hit a nice cute place
Shane no I met her in Fullerton brought
her back to Chino whoa yeah it sounds
like a beautiful country song you play
rap music nah nothing like that
I don't I don't know if I'm believing
this story it's very vague didn't
anything you want yeah we're asking you
we have no effort what was her name
I don't remember name hmm she went to a
different school was she tall Tomsk oh
she's tall and she was actually really
dark and that's one of the reasons why I
was like dark what about Nick I've dated
a half a half-black half-italian and she
was way more Italian but that doesn't
count right yeah sounds little dice you
need that no arms bark did I watch Baba
yeah I love I've watched both you guys
make love to a you know someone of
different descent yeah - but but Rihanna
Rihanna has always been my number one
Salieri's cuz you know she can throw it
down
go watch the music video unfaithful how
much does anybody throwing it down and
it's just [ __ ] its gravity you know
like dude see that's he that I know
you're born boy with your boring in the
sack bro I am you're lazy huh
I'm not lazy but I'm just you know I'd
rather do other stuff
you know see it back and you pull those
[ __ ] sweats just halfway down leave
your socks on yeah sometimes a row I
don't mean it depends on if it's cold
out or not yeah [ __ ] in there I don't
do that bro
I always keep my [ __ ] covered during
sex let us know what you think what else
you got from Julius Koivu MA
hello chin okay one of your guys I feel
one Big B greetings from Sweden
I was just wondering which football's
the real football the [ __ ] that you
play in the US or the one that the rest
of the [ __ ] world it is true so Theo
picks first okay so in this one I will
take I'll take soccer
I'll take soccer I'm gonna take soccer
because of this dude first of all
everybody can play soccer there's a
reason for that
the ball rolls the reason everyone can
play just a [ __ ] game carry on yeah
every not everyone can play football
carry on a lot more people have legs
than have legs and arms and you have to
have arms to play football correct
so an a soccer ball rolls dude a
football doesn't even [ __ ] roll bro
they took a ball and [ __ ] it up yeah
so it can't even really do anything yeah
you know it stop and go there's timeouts
there's referees dude soccer bro these
men I mean they're you know you could
bro you I've seen a soccer player jump
in the stands and breastfeed a child
they'll do whatever bro they play
year-round they play 45 minute halves so
you know it's a [ __ ] game but you know
dude and they go the whole time all
types of people can play skinny people
there's skinny people playing football I
don't see why she knows can play don't
see white play it's a universal sport
everyone can play soccer that's cuz some
big football no football is down to
mostly black men Tongans
and
you know white quarterback Johnny
McCaffrey or whatever that guy's name is
John McClane US and it's that's it
brother so you want a sport that yes
everyone can play
and yes it's a joy in the ball [ __ ]
rolls dude hey here's the ball
roll it to me oh I got it pretty basic
it's some basic big [ __ ] the thing I'll
give you for soccer those they're better
looking but the Premier League players
are some timepieces dude all everyone
has sleeves they make so much [ __ ]
money they're playing in Portugal and
[ __ ] Spain yeah Rocco the play by the
beach that's the best yeah in America
you want to pay you what Jacksonville
dude and they [ __ ] smoke their own
mud just one stop especially I played
some football in the day this one's
tough to defend just because you get
brain so I'm like a [ __ ] yeah
yes your quarterback brain from Macon is
a white dude dude yeah that's tough tar
you football football verse on soccer is
fun it you don't get head trauma
guaranteed money you're playing all over
the goddamn world everyone plays it it's
way bigger you arguing for soccer too
kind of man it's up this come from a
football player nothing let us know what
you think football or football the last
one this is a king in the sting history
our first on-air submission from a
female Matty Brewster oh I used to
[ __ ] hello damn girl yo my name is
Matty I'm from Austin Texas
I had a debate for you guys would you
rather have a girlfriend who was a 10
but she farts every three minutes and
the farts are super smelly or have a
girlfriend who is like a six but she's
vegan and she's got two cats damn you
damn baby blue blue eyes dude don't try
to rape some of the videos what's up
Frank Sinatra with the wig okay baby
blues baby blues thank you for that
submission young lady Maddie Brewster
first female who are you gonna go with
that is her first female submission so
it was it was a girl hot-ass girl who
farts every three minutes Mellie and
smelly or it's a decent girl who's a
vegan with cats yeah
well I'm allergic to cats and vegans
driving me nuts
and she's just basic I don't want to
deal with that [ __ ] I'll take the smoke
show who farts up the place
because what I'm gonna do is get some
thick-ass genes that filters that fart
yeah I don't put a silencer on her
[ __ ] and then I'm gonna I'm gonna
figure out a diet some sort of magic
potion where she farts and smells like
strawberries so I just have this smoke
show who's just dropping [ __ ]
freshener in the air like this non-stop
like Picabo Street but boom boom
rainbows on that ass rainbows grape Pina
Colada next week but Nana the sweet I
don't know bro but she's a [ __ ] smoke
show you fought it all you want girl
it's just thick pants she has all this
equipment on it and she's gonna fire no
she says like thyroid like you're dating
metals you don't look like Robocop but
you take all that off you look [ __ ]
hot dude it's gonna take you seven hours
in an Allen wrench to get that [ __ ] off
dude I like a girl you can [ __ ] quickly
on the fly there's a smoothie around
after this [ __ ] flaxseed on your dick
you know what I'm saying I'm talking
about a real vegan [ __ ] Street Queen
no kind of girl she'll swing right any a
bed off of a [ __ ] vine you know
smells like kind of a girl if you don't
like you're tired of dealing with this
[ __ ] us jump in a blender and just
[ __ ] smooth on out of your life we're
talking about a girl and maybe put a
little bit of a carrot in yes and a
couple of beats under your eyebrows
that's our getting freaky yeah that
hummus down your taint and the cat's
[ __ ] the distance bro yeah they said
cats but they didn't say what kind of
cast dude this [ __ ] has my hairless
Lynx's no she has the hairless cat no
like ball sacks all the eat is hummus
and bleep and then those cats are
farting that's what they don't tell you
that [ __ ] stink those cats know all
your secrets and live forever well
here's the other thing vegan smell dude
they do yeah they smell like the
goodwill but you can use their hair to
make wallets that's true and if Molly
and Emma brush their teeth oh I don't
believe in fluoride yeah more whose face
for you
you know they brush with peanuts do you
know that do they really chop them up
make a paste
my brother is ah I smell like shyly
allergic to sesame seed oil
I don't remember can't date a vegan then
yeah dude I'm taking a smoke show whoo
[ __ ]
and ripped up the farts I'm gonna come
up I'm gonna hurl smoke show dude you're
talking about a girl this girl she's
gonna be on tour after a while opening
up for [ __ ] uh that pants on the
ground guy who used to be um American I
tell my dear Tom pants on the ground
pants on the ground looking like a fool
my pants on the ground that guy one of
those you know one of your boys dude uh
who that what's that dance Jabberwock
one Jabberwock yeah I know exactly who
you want can oh don't don't [ __ ] touch
me dude shut up - [ __ ] stupid vegans
what else we got that's it for debate
club today but I win so alright bro yeah
I guess man you oh you got a yeah you
don't sound good dude
yeah all right it's time for King adore
sting it let's do it number one and just
like a debate club let us know your
responses after these guys King at our
sting it and we'll put you in the second
episode of the week this one comes from
Blake Hines Oh Blake Hines out of
Pittsburgh ooh oh yeah makes ketchup so
guys it was Blake for Boston big fan of
both years kegger stink for you is how
do you feel about non-violent cults like
an example Chris D'Elia his babies or
whatever they're called were to restart
a communist or something to do whatever
it is cults do kangaroo sing let me know
bro here's the thing
who the [ __ ] enters the cult list
there's danger involved told you call
you mean group of friends like this is a
called here you know I'm saying but I'm
not officially entering something I'm
not showing up all the [ __ ] time
every Monday afternoon to hang out with
you guys yeah for they that [ __ ] bro
then you don't know what it's like to be
a teammate and I'll say this that
Colin's cult leader nonviolent Colts
dude that could be anything family you
know gun owners people that Yogi's
Yogi's yeah a yoga motorcycle gang
motorcycle gang gay porters mmm those
[ __ ] dudes seem violent every like
once a year somebody when I'm he hits
the other one with the skateboard and
[ __ ] you know they get it on video
outside of a chef there's a stepmom
group that meets off La Cienega
yeah that's a cult step
yep's kids nonviolent Colts dude
Renaissance Fairs ah dude I mean what
you know Boy Scouts
that's a cult you can't trust those
[ __ ] and Chris Delia's cult bro
I don't trust them either that ain't
gonna end well
that thing is gonna end with everyone
drinking kool-aid except Chris and
everyone does well a lot of the people
gonna be drinking kool-aid cuz they're
underage girls probably it's just in
their natural diet pattern but I think
if you want to do a non-violent cult I
would start there that's cuz you're in
one bro well am I am one I guess I am
I'm in a few but when I was growing up
they had a group called wham whites
against Mexicans and here was the kicker
though he didn't have any Mexicans so it
was just a bunch of white guys I kind of
hung out and enjoyed just talking [ __ ]
yes but not for a while if you never
seen a Mexican there's not much to talk
[ __ ] about so it sounds like a group of
good dudes getting together once a week
yes shooting the [ __ ] I thought it was
over a couple cold ones yeah yeah and we
were kids so that's when beer really
[ __ ] hit you hard you know yeah so
yeah I would say do I support
non-violent Colts man I say King it I
say King you too yep alright next video
comes from Chuck Reeves
this is Chuckie reef most black king bee
sting my name's Chuck Reeves I am the
Beast host and I am the owner of this
wonderfully wonderful ginger face mullet
that you see before you is that chillin
ping it sting it no beard extensions
whether it's the clip-on type the so in
type the lace fronts or that spray-on
[ __ ] I know you're not necessarily
beard aficionados Theo who I know
doesn't love Allah with his baby face
and you would your glorious chin strap
there bee sting well say you the real
beard out damn that's a handsome man
that's the real beer is that real to see
of extensions I think ish it's real yeah
he's saying it's real dude if you don't
have a real one you using extensions get
the [ __ ] out my face bro really hell
yeah that's like a girl with a push-up
bra then you get home she released those
titties like what tough
[ __ ] dude get the chest a Theo von
wealth him with him you don't say you
need that real [ __ ] I'm not trying to
get that fake [ __ ] the clips and [ __ ]
extensions how insecure can you be it
grow it [ __ ] grow that [ __ ] out like a
real man you think so yeah well look man
a beard it's just you know it's just
hair coming out of your [ __ ] body
if you want extensions hail the [ __ ]
yeah dude no hello bro bro imagine a
black girl with a [ __ ] beard and a
[ __ ] big Charlotte you know and she
got some jingle bells laced into that
[ __ ] bra a little [ __ ] Chris not
supposed to have beards bro
only God made us but am i don't you have
that thick beard imagine big Lou Shelton
you know what I'm saying an equal to
hanging out you know he grew that you
know he's uh you know he's a Mason and
he's [ __ ] up he slices
oh yeah he's Kimbo slices and he grew
that [ __ ] out and he [ __ ] you know
he's getting that extension cuz he's
going to uh you know he's getting
married you talking about that Osama bin
Laden he won't set dragon tail [ __ ]
laced into that [ __ ] you know that's
beautiful man that Mike beltron yeah
imagine that why should and some guys
can barely grow a little like mine if I
try to grow a beard there's a handprint
where somebody was choking me when I was
young and no hair will grow there yeah
mine just gets all splotchy and it's
it's almost like a camouflage yeah I God
wanted me survive oh yeah I just blend
into the earth yeah grows in patches
yeah he look like a pyro higher bro
that's camera more oh it's natural
camera and [ __ ] extensions I say
sting the extension I say can King that
dope ass beard though yo so a jingle
Belling in that [ __ ] and enjoy your
holidays this is your turn
Thank You beard what else we got alright
next one is from Justin Hathaway some
more facial hair talk yeah this guy's
British I guess Oh Brendan Theo Justin
coming at you out of the great white
north of Michigan I feel tight dick
strong erection that was impressive
thank you I like we got working there
same better my king of they're stinging
for you guys is mustaches creepy or cool
firstly I think it's about as sexy as it
gets rocking a solid mustache so uh let
me know what you think king of your
stinking boys nah brah
every child molester ever mustache we
think every child molester ever hats I'm
a a most - nah moustache and sweats like
you got on but I don't judge you
cuz I know you're a good dude well you
were those sweats you touch kids the
thing is with him with the mustache
they're not cool anymore man must
actually unless your magnum p.i keep
that [ __ ] away from me unless it's
November and you're growing that [ __ ] on
purpose you can't rock it dude ask your
girl about it they don't dig them either
bro my stash unless you're a Mexican and
you're doing it for you know it's just
the way it grows in you can't do it oh
they had a Mexican infant on the
internet they had a mustache and I
thought it was beautiful dude and swell
goes bro
yeah I've seen girl mixing girls with
thick moustaches
I got her than mine way better New York
with Indian girls sometimes even have a
mustache all on their neck every time
I'm out a beard maybe yeah
you ever see yeah I've seen [ __ ]
Indian girls with [ __ ] mustaches on
the form
oh yeah yeah they fade it up
oh really fade yeah they fade up with a
zero guard just chilling on the forearms
yeah Billy fade is what I call them
[ __ ] hair bears out there oh yeah bro
now I'll say this man is that a mustache
I've had a mustache man and it is
there's something about when you lick
your own mustache it makes a little bit
of blood running to your pecker and it's
there's something you can't recreate
that in the world just that you ain't do
just not mmm but just that when you do
it everytime you lick your mustache you
know that something's dripping into your
system you know your morphine it's so if
you need something more you need to
[ __ ] work you know you need to do
something bad or [ __ ] pet an animal
real hard or [ __ ] there's a whole
nasty [ __ ] dude hard yeah you idiot well
I don't know they might fix a truck or
go for a run fast fast run downhill and
that's mainly to you
well something you got to do something
and that only comes and you lick a
[ __ ] mustache not you licking your
[ __ ] soft ass upper lip what kind of
dude get your [ __ ] what are you [ __ ]
Kevin Bacon what the [ __ ] is that I got
maybe yet that one I got that light
growth
yes that's super like you know I got
that word got that seventh-grade mixing
girls girls bro do whatever you bro wait
for everyone is it I can't grow a thick
Mustang can't no we'll get your [ __ ]
together man you're [ __ ] 4050 years
old
grow your [ __ ] out dude you know but
what I'm saying is when you lick that
thick something happens to you and you
can only do that with a mustache it's a
gentleman's gesture to grow a mustache
it is and you can't solve a crime
without a mustache mm look at Dateline
NBC or 78 you know days or whatever that
[ __ ] show is first 64 who's the most
famous mustache right now Sherlock
Holmes dude dude right now bro not your
old ass stories James Harden know is the
meanest mustache I can only think of old
ones like the Tom Selleck's and them
right like name a current dude who's
just rocking mustache man Dan Severn I
do hey this is old school [ __ ] chin has
a mustache now I just recognize that yep
I like a blank you're the first Chinese
dude I've ever seen facial hair yeah
Korean I mean yeah he's Korean dude
[ __ ] get it a name a Korean dude with
facial hair I can't that's me I'm a
Korean dish me neither
well now chin is your dad Harry uh he
could be if you want is your mom so I
love my mom Mary mom no good you ever
seen a Korean girl or asian girl there's
yeah I've seen one on Ebaum's world
you've had but what I'm saying is this
dude you I like a mustache on a black
man now that's something you don't see
very much don't [ __ ] touch it don't
[ __ ] touch me
yeah I agree it looks better on black
men you must s so I'd say beards looks
better on white dudes
it's very Ren Faire it's very Ren Faire
if you're a white guy in a mustard if
you're from Spain and get a mustache you
[ __ ] all the girls oh yeah you'll [ __ ]
a bull
whatever yeah okay I say King um ah god
I say sting it bro
sting the mustache it's just ain't the
50s are gone unless your name's Tom
Selleck it's over bro but it also keeps
your face warm
I'm Matt yeah he is from Michigan yeah
so his isn't bad if you're in California
the mustache you're a creep yeah what
else you got
alright the name of the next guy is
giggin heimer Keegan hi Murphy what's
going on Brandon what's going on Theo
rat king gang how's it going guys I know
a lot of people been doing these vapes
here yeah so uh what are your thoughts
King it sting as always much love to
both you guys get that 21s smoke out of
his face puff puff give and that guy
looks like he might not be alive a very
long and randon you know he called
Brendon Brandon his name was Keegan oh
that's Keegan [ __ ]
that's Keegan Kyle he's softly smoking
yeah he took a real rip off the the vape
and I don't mind the vape pens
especially when they got those delicious
flavors that they market to kids like
the unicorn cream or they got the
[ __ ] banana split or they got the
poppy seed [ __ ] blueberry I smelled
some of that charity they took delight
when you run through that cloud of smoke
oh my god it's like a treat for the day
yeah you get that creme brulee and
that's a basic hitter you get you get
that creme brulee my god did it'll make
you [ __ ] babysit your own dick dude I
saw dude just smoke that tiramisu Oh
Alysha s-- dude I went now that is
something I'd let somebody blow a puff
of [ __ ] they have crunchy peanut
butter and I don't let somebody blow it
chunk of that right in my ass man the
smoke I'm he know it's not the actual
car okay yeah that's intense yeah eight
pins man it's like having a little
choo-choo train just pull right into
your [ __ ] face all the flavor flavor
pill baby yeah it's flavor Ville full of
smoke imagine somebody just ties a bunch
of Doritos to a baseball bat just beat
you in the [ __ ] lungs with it and
that's what I love about Tam and Cheetos
in my it's like somebody filling your
mouths of [ __ ] bananas and just
beatin the [ __ ] out of it yeah you're
had that brisket babe oh that smoked
loin brother barbecue chicken babe
and aloha blow that Lord into my face oh
that's definitely King this shades
beautiful American cheese is a flavor to
that I've had this all cut off sweet
cheddar cheese vape bro just American
cheese cheddar bro I haven't had sweet
cheddar how you get you're missing out
yeah from England the final submission
is Alex work King everything maybe no
come on what's a median work work warum
lori thank you boy Alex from Nashville
Tennessee I got a question for the Rat
King
and the booster men's thongs thoughts oh
he looks like you rocked a thong and I
said it here on I'm too real proper you
get hairy dude now in the gay community
they call him a beer yeah yeah yeah they
call him just a big beautiful bear yep
leave that boy he's healthy but yeah
just trim up that beard too cuz run down
you know when the beard connects to your
chest hair mm-hmm that's what's going on
there well you just hear that she does
real proper yeah I tell you what that DS
never been punched in the face and I
have a wrinkle on his [ __ ] beautiful
skin I beautiful skin got some stem
cells off at that boy I hate to mouth
take them we know them stance they do
write a nice directly to my eyeballs I
was gonna say all right asses definitely
could have picked many other orifices
nah man gets right to the system
dude I'll [ __ ] pull the whole
question a suppliers and put him out of
my own mouth beautiful teeth I'll suck
on his eyeballs just draw nutrients baby
strong jaws dude I'll [ __ ] part that
dude shoulder hair with my tongue men's
socks men's thongs that's a handsome big
dude though basic floss for your [ __ ]
imagine to have a hard time again [ __ ]
stains in my undies now little loan a
thong
it's exhausting being a dude not to get
[ __ ] stains I don't even know dudes out
wear white undies you wear white uh not
anymore
what a horrible idea that was horrible
Hey look at the [ __ ] I had near hey look
at the pee pee stains in the front the
[ __ ] streaks in the back y'all
why would you why are you in the work
you ever seen a girl in a white thumb
never there's a reason for that
commercial maybe once in a while
a half-hour they'll do it like in the
summer yeah man she's fully [ __ ] hose
down without her hose down immediately
born after yeah otherwise you got
problems and also if a thong what if
you're like you know in a car ride or
you're driving all day and you just have
a piece of just cotton the stuff by your
[ __ ] I ain't doing that - I don't
want that [ __ ] razor blade through my
[ __ ] it's not sharp I don't think
it's cotton dude it's a hundred percent
ha ha sharp bro this after a while those
thongs get high especially once you mix
in the fluids that thing starts to
formulate bro well that's another thing
that thing can feel like a damn bra
strap if you wear it for a couple days
you know and what as a dude why would
you wear that though I feel bad for
girls I love them as I love them but I
have the bigger question is why in the
[ __ ] does Fruit of the Loom and BVD make
white drawers only really unbelievers
that who wants to see that [ __ ] drip
god damn unbelievable
of course everyone has pee pee stains I
don't care who you are I shake that [ __ ]
twice and this [ __ ] still drift
oh I'll even drip it into my hand like
kind of squeeze it out of my hand and
wash my hand in the sink
oh you squeeze it like like a toothpaste
kind of thing no not like roll up my
dick are you learning it out yeah kind
of now I shake it you know what I like I
don't shake it all you'll drip on my
hand and [ __ ] it ok ok swine flu a guy
Wow diddle [ __ ] dirty dick over here
little BP hand oh yeah dude I'm just
saying white undies make no sense and a
thong sure [ __ ] doesn't make sense yes
sting it in bro if you send us that
video with a thong on I salute you sir
bro any future asses so here yeah you
got so much hair down there bro I say no
on the thong Oh word cool that's it for
King under sting it and before we go
we're gonna launch a new segment it's
the inaugural flaunt my aunt oh yeah
let's do it for this do it for the fans
out there submit your pictures of your
aunt uncle nieces nephews older
obviously grandma grandpa mom dad step
step dad whatever you want man
and then we're chiming just tell you how
we feel about them yeah don't send any
children don't say that yeah you just
had about seven bad ideas in a row bro
you're like a bad idea like I'm like a
infomercial late at night terrible ideas
you want stamps you're like an ak-47 of
bad ideas Senate pictures you're on and
may end yeah we can a family member who
of is of a of age yes yes girlfriend's
boyfriend's here here's my submission
first this is my aunt Debbie she's on
the Left bro let's get that aunt cam
going dude who's mr. steal your man on
the right though is that your grandma
with that perm that's my grandma Kay who
raised me damn flaunting bro in you and
girl McKay look-alike honestly yeah yeah
she definitely has more style than you
bro aunt case doing the damn thing can
we zoom in yeah one sec oh that's your
aunt could be anyone on the left bank
not going to do it your grandma swaggy
swaggy bro my she's 84 years old in that
picture damn she's still alive yep damn
your Emily she's married bro he's not
she says she's single i Brendan you have
my blessing but I Rome what is going on
you mind even in for a second earrings
there you go well I can see it from
there all right can we scroll up a
little on her so we can just get to full
she got the Dog the Bounty Hunter
sunglasses on though that's how it works
back then that it that is aunt Debbie
okay Wow all right Deborah I like that
she's got that old Navy performance
fleece she's rocking she's out there
she's got those the Landon's jeans on
very land and at the end of the land
she's on their own I
she's looking out on someone I'm
distracted by your by your grandma with
their booty perked out in the [ __ ]
she's in the Texas tuxedo in the firm
bro with the gold chain she looks like
Kerri yeah [ __ ] Flossie bro she looks
like Kerry Von Erich stepdad Ebro she
looks [ __ ] beautiful right oh yeah
she looked like she was a [ __ ] side
piece of David Bowie back in those she
definitely looked like she hung out
around the Alamo you know what I'm
saying you know she looked like she hung
around staple centers in this in the 60s
you know I'm saying folks he got my eyes
yeah I love your grandma's [ __ ]
swaggy P over here bro very beautiful
and I'll say this about the aunt she's a
blonde she's a natural blonde you know
and she's got the sunshine in her hair
and she's out there looking you know she
has two arms two legs
she loves the rescue animals if that
helps Wow she loves rescues right
flaking she looks nice she looks like
the type of woman who just take you off
the street give you a cup of cocoa and a
nice [ __ ] sweater from Eddie Bauer
yes she definitely seemed like she'd get
you that Eddie Bauer she looks like she
has just hot dogs on her all the time to
feed the homeless
yep feed well yeah she gots a good thing
bro I could see her with a little tree a
snack to make sure everybody stays
healthy and hydrated she looks like she
has peppermints in her pocket yeah I
could see her maybe with a man or
something not yet give her another five
or six years for she's now where they
posted up of this picture this is
someplace on the Mississippi River
she Brownsville Minnesota and lacrosse
Wisconsin one of the two damn your aunt
said hold up [ __ ] let me post up right
quick
and your aunt seems like a lady that
definitely probably you know I would say
she seemed like she watches if she had a
show that she watched I bet probably
NCIS how you think yep mmm she looks
like she watches my 600-pound life like
she just she just [ __ ] binge watches
TLC like she's down for born this way
she's down for [ __ ] the transgender
shuttle lost and pumpkin farmers of
little ones yeah the little ones who
would [ __ ] riches [ __ ] but they're
mean the [ __ ] I'm not super sure of
her viewing
habits but she did when I was back home
she made me write down the name of this
show so she will be checked oh that's
cool your grandma looks like she she
watches Wilin out
oh definitely yeah your grandma's
grandma oh yeah bro she loves action
movies we watched skyscraper when I was
back [ __ ] yeah I bet you do doing her
bro yeah I bet she watches Wilin out and
just [ __ ] rips all get Nick Cannon
lines and [ __ ] she looks like the white
uh Spike Lee a little bit but sexier and
a woman yeah more accomplished and more
accomplished yeah I mean she's with her
grandma's rich she looks like she has
some money your grandma looks like she
has a Rolex underneath that [ __ ] Texan
tuxedo
well she cleans up nice brother hear ya
there and uh the multiple gold chains
bro and dude I'll say this she's
swagging more than Debbie is in this
picture hey Simon clothes Debbie shoulda
brought it you know what grandma was
bringing it Debbie Debbie was like I
[ __ ] grandma I didn't know we were going
full out today that's true that's true
Debbie is married though so she's in
that my grandma's single and looking
looking Oh shoes Oh your grandma hungry
yeah yeah you've got we got the hungry
[ __ ] blurry eyes well calm down and
it's great to see both of these women
she actually just had cataract surgery
so she seems yeah that's what I'm still
thinkin since before she was like
looking she was thirsty but it's the way
it goes bro I had surgery on my eyes I
couldn't see forever
look I said gonna but dudes for the long
time so I got my eyes worked on you know
I'm saying you look like [ __ ] let's get
another aunt beautiful Debbie thank you
for my not out to your [ __ ]
swaggy P grandma bro what the [ __ ] is
your aunt's name chin in it what is it
Hannah aunt Anna and Hannah Hannah any
god damn it Hanna with all respect King
yeah bro give it up give it up give it
up with your sweats Bronco Tony I [ __ ] a
new chin was hole now dude your aunt
you [ __ ] some houses Oliver and this
is no disrespect
zero bro is she single now she's not
saying she's married to your uncle
snared my uncle they have kids they got
kids you're [ __ ] right they dude look
at that mommy leave that [ __ ] mommy
she a blood aunt yeah
damn she's quran's this part a little
bit of Korean in there god damn I bet I
chopped it down brother [ __ ] right you
would oh I'd share a [ __ ] double
scoop orange chicken with her and talk
about things
oh I karate kick her right into my bed
bro what I'm talking about is she seemed
like a nice lady dude I'd watch a
marathon of [ __ ] The Last Samurai
with her with my dick out my aunt yeah
this is all good these are compliments
where did she go to school at Harvard in
Texas I've never heard of it Harvard
well there's a lot of schools in Texas
and there's a lot of not schools in
Texas um she looks like a nice lady did
she bartend or not [ __ ] right she's
obviously made Bank bro
what's your uncle look like it's a
curricular dude
oh yeah the Asian or not is he is is he
out kicking his coverage kicking this
coverage yeah yeah like yeah he's a
lucky dude I'd say he's pretty lucky
that he looks like [ __ ] he's lucky my
uncles it look like [ __ ] over there it's
flaunt your on yes say something nice
about the diamonds and I've been dating
a lot [ __ ] behind her at a bar no I
did it you asked if she weren't if she
[ __ ] could put tequila together does
she drink a lot I don't [ __ ] know she
does she go to a lot of raves she do a
lot of ecstasy on the weekends [ __ ] I
don't know man but she looks like she's
down down to hang out and have a good
time
yeah she's how old is she yeah that's a
good question I think maybe in like mid
40 mm think about Asians bro you me get
you an agent deal you cannot tell they
don't age but then 80 comes boom
cinderella father time they age like
fruit
oh they disappear at night they turn
into a yellow squash but I'll say this
dude - chanting actually 40s if not
fifties
oh Jesus and we shot a body or not you
it seemed like she was in the gold rush
or something she has a very you know
kind of authentic sort of look kind of
you know her hair used to be like up
here the Texas big Texas hair
so she's trimmed it down a little bit
but it's still high and she has a little
bit of southern twang to that Texas
twine sure man honey calls her own honey
oh she looks like she me makes a mean
[ __ ] bitsy stand grazie she makes
such good food and his food rescue see
that there she makes brisket the best
this is wyfy son
how many kids uh three and they're all
your age go no they're younger oh yeah I
could see that damn she seemed like
somebody that would get water from the
river and like just ya know medicine
does she know anything about medicine or
ministers she looks like she gives a
natural cures like she gives a good back
rub and then reads [ __ ] tarot cards
she's strong
oh dude I'd let that lady beat the [ __ ]
out of me me too does she know Conklin
she knows her condo probably a little
[ __ ] knew it man she looks like it
handle herself
oh I'd let her run over me with a car
until I came dude I would I would share
a full rack of ribs with a Chili's
wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah she seems like
a nice lady and a melon she seems super
nice yeah my own flop my aunt shut up
the chins on shut up - [ __ ] Knicks
grandma for the sidekick they're right
the aunt just got out shine shopping
it's grandma bro hey dude I think we got
a segment here though bro okay I got
height for your family bro I got high
for your family bro no I can't think
about chins out and Knicks grandma bro I
just want Nick and chin to make it out
of here safely
thank God me too I went there the same
DNA in them um well look I think this is
another good practice episode I mean to
man the real thing kicks off next week
real studio real [ __ ] production yeah
the real bullets are flying Nick's grams
gonna be in studio
[Laughter]
dripping that swaggy P on that bring
your [ __ ] mints and [ __ ] if he's sick
Wow row she's that nice she's a new
Rihanna bro oh yeah I'm not the sliding
the chins on
and [ __ ] just to say what's up yeah and
get the brisket menu that's all I'm
doing a lot of beautiful ladies I want
to thank a lot of the young men also
that sinem videos today all the everyone
who send the videos you guys make this
show happen yeah so the top should come
up with if this shows good it's because
of you guys and the submissions and all
that so keep cementing them and then
again the best of and if you disagree
agree maybe have better points which I'm
sure you guys aren't better points than
us submit those videos so you get seen
on the [ __ ] YouTube page on Friday
yeah we're gonna put the follow-up
episode on Friday and that will
encapsulate like you guys his thoughts
on the debates and on the king ander
staying it and then also send the
pictures of your aunts uncles grandmas
dad mom girlfriends boyfriends whatever
you want so we can flaunt your arm baby
let's say got me hi oh my god that's
crazy yeah crazy for [ __ ] next
graphic okay we are talking bro all
right we I get out of here probably get
naughty yeah I gotta get arrested
I've got long hair I'm getting the [ __ ]
out easy
[Music]